one points he's ready we send it to Ali
leforce Joel congratulations on the win
41 last night 41 tonight tennis say
seven rebounds how do you explain this
historic streak that you're on um just
letting the game come to me um but you
know how the credit goes to those guys
they put me in the best position to
succeed and they trust me that's a key
you know I would not be doing that you
know without the trust they have in me
so but we're doing as a team I mean I'm
just finishing that place the world was
waiting to watch this matchup between
Joel embiid and Nicole yic but they're
also dying to know what you said to each
other after that tough fight I didn't
hear the last part they're also dying to
know what you two asked each other and
said to each other during that last hug
I just thought him he the best play in
the league like I told you earlier you
know he you know he won the championship
that's the best team in the league and
you know he's the final MVP so I just
tell him keep going see and see you in
two weeks and keep doing your thing and
that's why you're the best in the league
great game Joel thank you uh great
respect that was a lot of
fun